the final assembly of an Airbus 320 a
medium-range passenger jet used by
hundreds of airlines worldwide 36 year
old Hika Auto heads one of the three
production lines she has a team of
mechanics electricians and fitters I've
heard you're catching up pretty fast
even though you're short on people
she studied Business Administration I
used to do customer service in an office
and I'd wonder where the products came
from I always wanted to go into
production and I fallen in love with it
don't when you've had to go yep are you
managing a team of 230 coworkers is not
an easy task the pressure is enormous
production has to be cost-effective
without making compromises on quality
get ready for tomorrow does everyone
know what to do she's responsible for
keeping the operation going
you should kryten's in every two and a
half days we have to roll a finished
airplane out of our line one and to keep
up in spite of all the problems that can
crop up you have to work together with
all the contact people to find quick
solutions and replace partner Austin
proscenium from two longer mines um to
keep up with the international
competition Airbus has to keep
developing and refining their models
generally for aircraft types are
assembled in Hamburg Germany's main
production site with the runway of its
own and some 13,000 workers
among those workers is mechanic Sondra
Miller right now work is underway on the
cargo hold of an a330 I know I'm
installing one of the outlet valves
these valves are in both cargo holds one
in front of the wing and one behind it
they regulate the cabin pressure it's
not easy to get a job with Airbus
thousands of people apply each year
Sondra Miller is 23 she was accepted
because of her good grades she'd set her
sights on a technical occupation only
14% of Airbus's staff are women I like
the little princess here I get along
with everyone we kid around but
sometimes you have to have a thick skin
my coworker is often still act like
little boys but if you can hold your own
it's a lot of fun here my Spectre spazio
back to the Airbus 320s final assembly
the side and ceiling panels have to be
in by the end of the day the fitters
work on the insulation before putting in
about 150 seats
Hika auto takes management seminars
regularly it's important for her to know
how to communicate effectively
he marked the I admit invention yeah I
like working with the people here I like
the co-workers who've got their heart in
the right place and we're done their
sleeves
I like the production of airplanes and
their technology it's fun to make things
possible that would otherwise be
impossible
Hika Otto has been in charge of the
final assembly line here for more than a
year now and that adds up to about 90
completed aircraft